what do you think about Ron DeSantis do  you think he's a Warhawk uh you you you  have to be critical of everyone  um you never you never put all your eggs  in one basket you never prop up any man  above yourself uh that's number one so  never give any politician a benefit of  the doubt so let him prove himself let's  see what he does let's see what he says  let's ask him some real questions uh  there are some bad people surrounding  him which we should be critical of uh  but he's in his he's in the dialogue  he's making big moves that of course are  making uh National discussions  especially among smokness especially  what's happening in schools especially  what's happening with the vaccines those  conversations wouldn't happen if it  wasn't for him so therefore overall  those conversations are good and then  that positive Donald Trump is not being  a part of the conversations he is  selling nfts and he's not on Twitter